le consacre ses premiers pas à
l'étranger à l'ukraine la ministre
française catherine colonna est donc à
kiev ce lundi une visite surprise et un
déplacement symbolique notamment à butch
à là où des centaines de civils
ukrainiens ont été retrouvés morts après
le départ des russes la chef de la
diplomatie qui a tenu une conférence de
presse que vous avez suivi du leader
craag bonjour gulliver vous êtes notre
correspondant que retenez vous
alors c'était la conférence de presse
avec sa rencontre avec son homologue
ukrainien dmitro koulouba catherine
colonna n'a pas fait d'annoncé nouvelle
de livraisons d'armes qu'est ce que le
cren demande en premier lieu de 8
roucouler bas lui a réitéré son
explication pour ce pourquoi l'ukraine a
tellement besoin de ces armes et
catherine colonna a dit que c'était ton
discussions et elle a aussi parlé d'un
soutien pour la reconstruction de
l'ukraine promis par emmanuel macron de
l'ordre de 2 milliards de dollars c'est
beaucoup mais l'ukraine estime que c'est
déjà plus de 600 milliards de dollars
dont le pays aura besoin pour sa
reconstruction une fois que cette guerre
sera finie et bien sûr la guerre
continue dans une question sur les
négociations en cours avec la russie à
quel stade sont nés les négociations
c'est un journaliste français qui a posé
cette question admis trop coulé bas et
il a répondu eh bien ces négociations
sont au stade où la russie maintient la
pression sur le dos de basse et teddy
une grande partie de ses forces armées à
la prise de severodonetsk bombarde nos
villes en ce moment des civils sont
morts donc les négociations sont
absolument au point mort c'est à quoi à
catherine colonna à compte c'est était à
son tour de prendre la parole a dit oui
on comprend que en ce moment ce n'est
pas le moment pour les négociations
parce que les combats intenses se
sentent en cours en ce moment mais elle
a dit que la france souhaite vivement se
poser au médiateur une fois que le
moment serait venu pour les négociations
rapidement gulliver parce que vous devez
intervenir côté anglophone de france 24
la visite se poursuit puisque catherine
colonna seront je crois dans une caserne
elle va remettre aux ukrainiens du
matériel de sécurité civile s'est
où exactement je comprends bien ce sont
des ambulances et des camions de
pompiers
je vais me rendre moi même si je suis là
où je suis en ce moment et pas devant la
caserne c'est parce que les
embouteillages sont réapparus à kiev
avec la population qui revient donc en
quelque sorte c'est bon signe quand on
constate que la vie commence à reprendre
sa cour normal à kiev mais ce qui fait
aussi qu' on est parfois en retard vive
les embouteillages en ukraine merci
beaucoup gilbert craag